[Musique]
bonjour nouveau numéro de pourvu que ça
dure des missions qui rend les
co-responsables sur public sénat
aujourd'hui nous avons parlé de la
digitalisation de l'économie et tous les
dirigeants d'entreprise vous le diront
la pandémie a précipité la
transformation numérique de leurs
sociétés ce qui impacte évidemment notre
façon de produire et de travail et vous
verrez comment le loueur avis a basculé
en quelques mois dans un modèle 100%
numérique ou encore comment l'atelier
des chefs c'est complètement réinventé
ce qu'il est ouvert de nouveaux horizons
et puis la paix des deux picards nous
racontera comment la mis le paquet sur
le digital dès son arrivée à la tête de
l'entreprise en juin 2020 en pleine
crise pandémique mais d'abord que
recouvre ce terme de numérisation on
vous explique tout en moins d'une minute
c'est parti la digitalisation c'est quoi
au juste transformer tous les processus
manuels par des technologies digitales
le courrier est devenu lé email le
magasin une boutique en ligne un salon
événementiel un forum désormais tout se
traite en ligne alors comment ça marche
on commence par fabriquer un site
internet c'est la première vitrine pour
le client puis une appli 60% des
français naviguent plus sur leur
téléphone que sur leur ordinateur
enfin on s'équipe de logiciels de métier
pour être payés réserver une salle faire
la comptabilité
rédiger les certificats de travail signé
les contrats gérer les agendas recruter
les employés se réunir en
visioconférence commander un taxi la
digitalisation et l incontournable
oui si on veut faire face à la
concurrence et à voir une croissance
forte durable
grâce à la digitalisation on gagne du
temps on travaille de partout quand on
veut et surtout l'entreprise devient
plus flexible et plus réactive les
entreprises qui digitalise sont plus
performantes de 26% la crise a accéléré
ce phénomène les boîtes qui ont fait ce
choix on gagnait 7 ans
et oui la crise accélérée comme jamais
le besoin de transformation digitale des
entreprises jean matthieu courtecuisse
bonjour david persia troll avec nos
présidents de sya partners la crise
sanitaire l'a vraiment changé la proche
qu'on les entreprises de leur
transformation digitale il ya vraiment
un avant et un après je crois qu'on peut
déjà commencer par la vie du quotidien
on voit tous aujourd'hui qu'on fait plus
souvent nos courses en ligne qu'on fait
des consultations de télémédecine ou
qu'on télétravail tout ça ça n'existait
pas avant donc c'est la crise c'est une
révolution des usages d'abord et donc ce
besoin d'accélération toutes les
entreprises ressentent à la fois parce
que au cours de la crise a été un
facteur de résistance de résilience
toutes les entreprises qu'ils étaient
les plus digitalisation celles qui ont
le mieux résisté et aujourd'hui une
révolution de l'offre qui est en train
de s'opérer donc des changements dans la
façon de consommer les changements dans
la façon de travailler il faut gérer
tous en même temps j'ai envie de dire
une vraie transformation profonde
transformation digitale sas ligne pas
numériser la paye la compta ou ou avoir
un site web c'est c'est d'abord se poser
des questions existentielles
alors il ya pour une entreprise bright
food a fait alors il y avait
effectivement pendant très longtemps le
numérique ça servait à faire de la
productivité
parfois de l'agilité et maintenant c'est
au coeur de la construction de l'offre
qui va auprès des clients des
entreprises donc c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui a changé radicalement
on utilise d'abord une série de
technologies qui était là depuis un
certain temps on a basculé dans le monde
du cloud dans tout le monde sait à peu
près ce que c'est donc sa i stay depuis
dix ou quinze ans simplement là on est
passé à l' échelle donc il ya eu d'abord
une dimension déchets sur l'exploitation
des technologies et surtout une nouvelle
génération de technologies qui arrivent
les façons de travailler
voilà on a tous vécu les frustrations du
zoom du team zh ces outils vont changer
avant la crise on avait 50 millions
d'utilisateurs au quotidien aujourd'hui
on n'a plus d'avenir donc il ya des
flots d'argent considérables qui arrive
dans ses solutions et elles vont se
transformer très vite elles vont
proposer de la réalité virtuelle de
l'holographie dont on est au début de
l'histoire qui se construit après cette
révolution digitale cette transformation
digitale est touche d'abord les grands
groupes ou n'importe quelle pme
entreprises familiales est concerné je
crois au lit aussi que la crise a
apporté la preuve que tout le monde
avait cet impératif de transformation
quelle que soit la taille est que soit
le secteur en réalité on est tous
concernés et donc parfois se sont pas
forcément les plus grandes entreprises
qui se les prépare mieux parfois sur les
plus petites qu'ils ont montré une
grande forme d'agilité vous allez voir
les restaurateurs qui se sont très vite
adaptés à la livraison des repas en
ligne certains auront par contre connu
des vraies difficultés pour un
restaurateur ce qu'on gagne en livrant à
la maison le père aussi en salle en
restaurant c'est ça aussi se poser la
question d'être en 76 ya ce qu'on perd
dans le monde physique et puisqu'on peut
gagner dans le monde utilisent
effectivement le digital pro s'agit de
l'expérience et cette expérience allait
désormais omni canal et à la maison à
distance et vous pouvez aussi convaincre
des clients de votre restaurant qui
faisait juste de la livraison de venir
aussi dans votre espace de restauration
ci s'ils sont convaincus par ce qu'ils
ont reçue à la maison donc tout peut
finalement se polliniser et apporter
quelque chose de plus la vraie question
c'est plutôt le type de nouvelle
concurrence qui peut arriver c'est à
dire que les entreprises qui existent
elles ont un passé un passif et quelque
chose à transformer alors que parfois
des nouveaux entrants eux arrivent ex de
la page blanche donc ça peut être pas
prendre exemple des constructeurs
automobiles avec les traditionnelles et
historique qui en fit production qui a
depuis longtemps et puis les nouveaux
tesla ou d'autres qui arrivent et from
scratch commenté en partant de rien avec
des usines beaucoup plus robotisée dès
le départ c'est pareil que les banques
en ligne vous avez des banques qui des
mains
sur une nouvelle page puis d'autres qui
doivent se transformer donc c'est plutôt
cette cette question de la
transformation versus la création qui
est vrai qu'après il faut que les
salariés soit embarqué dans cette grande
aventure de la transformation digitale
il faut qu'ils soient formés justement
pour accompagner ce changement selon
elle ce risque d'être un petit peu je
sais pas moi marginalisés
inemployables comment on s'assure que
tout le monde aura les compétences
notamment de numérique pour être
embarqué cette transformation d'abord
numérique c'est touche à la fois la
sphère privée et la sphère
professionnelle donc on est quand même
tous inciter à évoluer dans nos usages y
compris à la maison donc ça c'est le
premier élément
le deuxième élément c'est que la plupart
des grandes entreprises ont en effet
lancé des programmes de ce qu'on appelle
deux skilling pour entrer en gare de
vente en puissance exactement et pour
rafraîchir en fait la façon dont ça
pouvait se passer mais c'est vrai que
des phénomènes de rupture notamment dans
la compréhension des nouveaux modes de
consommation c'est ça qui peut parfois
amener une fracture générationnelle
puisque une fracture technologique
et donc il y a pour les entreprises
cette nécessité encore une fois de
former leurs collaborateurs aux
changements et aux changements on s'en
tenait même les dirigeants je pense
qu'aujourd'hui le cartable encore des
parts et les dirigeants bas parfois ça
peut arriver parce que il ya c'est aussi
parfois pas forcément les plus jeunes
dans la dans l'entreprise ou qui sont
pas forcément les plus ouverts à la
technologie mais on voit bien
aujourd'hui avec l'arrivée du monde de
l'art était virtuel ce casque à
conceptualiser un certain nombre
d'acteurs de la tête qui s'appelle de
metaverse aujourd'hui n'importe quelle
grande entreprise de voir une stratégie
mais terre c'est à dire savoir stratégie
metaverse c'est à dire se savoir se
déployer dans le monde virtuel dans
lequel nous allons vivre très rapidement
la façon de consommer de dans la façon
d'acheter la façon de travailler donc on
est équipés de casques de réalité
virtuelle très rapidement on aura tous
nos avatars temps qu'on va vous écouter
on est en train de vivre une une
décennie de transformation inédite on y
est là et la crise et pandémiques la la
provoc elle a accéléré oui d'abord parce
que pour la première fois on va pouvoir
mobiliser des gains de productivité qui
n'avait pas réussi à faire depuis quinze
ou vingt ans
bénéficient de ces outils depuis
longtemps mais les gains de productivité
on les voyait pas arriver là ils sont là
grâce aux outils numériques
exactement et parce qu'il ya eu des
changements relativement fort dans les
usages sur le selon les usages on a
gagné 2,5 10 ans parlait tout à l'heure
la télémédecine
l'explosion des consultations en
télémédecine qui pouvait imaginer que ça
arriverait aussi vite le télétravail on
imaginait plutôt qui s'adresse cette
instance était là en 2030 2035 donc
cette accélération la permet de réaliser
des gains de productivité absolument
formidable donc au final il ya un avant
vraiment un après je reviens ma première
question il ya un avant et un après pour
les entreprises dans leur approche de
leur transformation digitale vadillo qui
aura pas de retour en arrière par
rapport aux colombiens bon voila merci
mathieu matthieu courtecuisse donc le
président de six apart 1 alors chez avis
ou à l'atelier des chefs l'a dit
réalisation a fait un grand bond en
avant et pendant la crise sanitaire
reportage signé manuel l'aigre
depuis quelques années peu importe leur
taille les entreprises sont en pleine
mutation numérique les tâches manuelles
sont remplacés par des technologies
digitales et cette tendance s'accélère
avec la crise sanitaire certaines
entreprises ont même gagné sept ans sur
leur transformation numérique
[Musique]
c'est le cas d'avis l'un des leaders
français de location de voiture avec sa
nouvelle application le client n'a plus
aucun contact humain un écran remplace
l'agent d'accueil lui indique le numéro
de place de parking les clés et le
contrat sont sur le tableau de bord
n'a plus qu'à servir à prendre le
véhicule est à partir pas donc en fait
tout se fait directement sur
l'application donc 50 ans
pour les plus sceptiques un guichet
reste ouvert pour l'instant seuls 37%
des clients ont opté pour la version
digitale
bonjour
ouais reprendre le terme et s'il vous
plaît c'est le seul contact humain que
vous avez là c'est le seul ouais en fait
ils vérifient vraiment que ce soit bien
ou qu'il comprenne notre permis et donc
après y'a plus qu'à partir
vous aussi merci au revoir
avis détient environ 500 points de
location en france ces dispositifs
numériques restent encore marginaux ces
zones ont été développées depuis trois
ans on accélère clairement aujourd'hui
on a six zones aujourd'hui qui sont
principalement des aéroports et des
gares c'est les investissements qui sont
entre 100 et 150 mille euros par station
à chaque fois qu'on veut mettre cette
digitalisation
l'entreprise continue d'investir et de
multiplier ces zones 2.0 partout en
france un virage numérique onéreux mais
vitale dans les années à venir
c'est encore un investissement
je pense que la rentabilité va arriver
assez rapidement parce que la
satisfaction client ramène plus de
clients la rapidité ramène encore plus
de clients donc pour nous c'est capturer
de nouveaux clients par rapport à ces
visites animations
tous les secteurs se lance dans cette
course folle à la digitalisation comme
l'atelier des chefs et ses cours de
pâtisserie en ligne ce disque lui sert
essentiellement de base à de très
nombreux
et précis l'abrutissement
marie 39 ans est juriste elle n'aurait
jamais imaginé suivre une formation de
six semaines en pâtisserie par écran
interposé ce qui paraît surprenant en
fait pour la pâtisserie parce que c'est
quelque chose de très pratique
maintenant la formation est très bien
faite parce qu'on a une partie théorique
puis on a des petites vidéos en fait qui
nous montre les gestes à acquérir mais
c'était quelque chose on a besoin de
sentir de touché mais en tout cas
d'avoir un professionnel à côté soit
vous apprenez aussi à développer vos
sens et puis on apprend aussi qu à
partir d'une photo la texture
visuellement en fait la texture va
permettre de déterminer si ces ratés ou
pas et ça on apprend en fait en le
faisant moi ça m'est arrivé et
maintenant à l'oeil je sais voir si ma
pâte à choux elle va être bonne hulu si
eva est raté
la formation s'adresse à tous peu
importe le niveau et le matériel dont on
dispose en étant maman de trois enfants
le faire en présentiel pour moi c'était
pas possible en fait c'était pas gérable
avec la logistique familiale du coup
c'était un super compromis parce que du
coup je pouvais me mettre une fois que
les enfants étaient couchés ou quand les
enfants étaient à l'école ça me
permettait de pouvoir me consacrer à
100% à ma formation
le digital
ccc le la clé pour demain
et marie est loin d'être la seule
cliente satisfaites aujourd'hui le
distanti elle est devenue une réelle
industrie
donc on a plusieurs cuisines c'est
vraiment notre métier historique puisque
on fait de la formation en présentiel
avec ici des gens qui vont cuisiner plus
que de la pâtisserie quant à côté ils
goûtent faire de la cuisine faute de
place les formations sont limités à une
quinzaine de stagiaires pour augmenter
son chiffre d'affaires françois dû faire
un choix louer des locaux
supplémentaires ou plus improbables
investir dans un plateau de télévision
là on va voir maintenant le studio donc
là où on fait toutes nos formations
digital et donc nos formations on a une
cuisine pardon dans lesquels on va
pouvoir faire toutes nos préparations et
toutes nos vidéos de cuisine de
pâtisserie de boulangerie un pâtissier
six caméras des techniciens et des
dizaines de vidéos inédites
chaque année
[Musique]
ce qui est très important c'est que pour
faire de la formation aux vidéos
d'informations digitales il faut que la
qualité soit absolument topissime est en
fait c'est pour ça que pendant un temps
les gens avaient peur de la formation
digital c'est qu'ils avaient
l'impression que l'image et la qualité
allait être médiocre aujourd'hui avec ce
matériel assez du matériel
qu'effectivement on va retrouver dans
des pour faire des émissions de
télévision
aujourd'hui 5000 clients sont inscrits à
la formation en ligne des inscriptions
en perpétuelle augmentation
sur la formation digital on a fait 100 %
de croissance pendant trois ans et donc
notre enjeu c'est de multiplier par dix
neuf chiffre d'affaires dans les cinq
prochaines années en moyenne les
entreprises ayant fait le choix de la
digitalisation serait plus performante
de 26%
le loueur avis l'atelier des chefs de
nombreuses entreprises ont accéléré leur
virage digital dans cette crise
sanitaire à l'image de l'enseigné de
surgelés picard
bonjour cathy collart jachère bonjour
c'est roland petit chaque année
installez-vous merci quand vous arrivez
à la tête de puits car on est en juin
juin 2020 et on est en plein coeur de la
crise sanitaire et vous fait ce constat
lucide implacable diront certains que
picard est en retard sur le digital
c'est ça le constat quand vous arrivez
oui puisque comme je dirai tout
commerçant fait on a assisté à
l'explosion des achats en ligne aussi
sur les produits surgelés pendant le
premier confinement et vous n'étiez pas
prêts et nous n'étions pas prêts puisque
ont livré à l'époque 25 % du territoire
français c'est parce que c'est plus de
400 à chaud c'est sa force a encore dit
oui bon voila et lors du premier
confinement vous n'êtes pas pu honorer
toutes vos commandes pas toutes les
commandes des clients ce qui comme
problématique on entre dans un délai
relativement long
pour ce qui est de la nourriture
effectivement bon donc à votre arrivée
vous vous dites je mets le paquet sur
digital ce sera l'une des premières
décisions entre autres effectivement ça
a été de mettre en route un vrai plan de
croissance pour saisir toutes les
opportunités que proposait finalement
cette période alors on a commencé par la
livraison à domicile puisque c'était la
première demande finalement des français
pendant cette période et on venait de se
le dire 25 % du territoire donc mon
ambition c'était 100% tout de suite du
territoire donc on l'a adressé d'abord
avec notre propre flotte que l'on avait
déjà et on a construit un partenariat
avec chrono fraîche pour aller couvrir
finalement le reste du territoire
français et on a commencé effectivement
à ouvrir un premier entrepôt en octobre
2020 également et puis on a mis en place
tout le click and collect donc on est en
train de déployer donc on a testé du
click and collect pour vérifier
l'appétence des clients à ce type de
modèle et puis janvier 2021 on a testé
aussi la livraison express notamment
avec des livres ou pour voir si là aussi
les sens pour nos clients et s'apprend
très bien ça prend très bien puisque nos
clients sont livrés en moins de dix
minutes voyez
et donc ce qui est intéressant c'est que
ça touche notamment les jeunes qui sont
une population qu'on voulait en tout cas
séduire dans notre enseigne donc donc
c'est intéressant donc pour attirer les
millénium notamment il faut plus de
digital évidemment il faut plus de
digital il faut varier les parcours
parce qu'on a une vie qui est multiple
on va tantôt au magasin tantôt ce fait
livrer tantôt on veut passer en click
and collect donc il faut savoir
s'adapter finalement parcours de vie des
clients la moitié des utilisateurs de
ces nouveaux parcours sont des nouveaux
clients pour la marque ne consommez pas
picard avant et qui on commence à le
faire via le digital et qui ont commencé
à faire via le digital et puis on avait
des des clients qui étaient fidèles à
nos magasins qui ont finalement mixer
comme on dit on les appelle les clients
omni canaux ceux qui sont à la fois en
digital et et en physique
les rendre justement hominick anovo
clients c'est ça aussi l'objectif qu'ils
achètent à la fois physique et aussi
amusé à l'envers on dépense plus quand
on est aveugle en fait on est plus
fidèle et donc on dépense plus c'est
chez nous c'est deux fois plus soyons et
en inaugurant ce pas au détriment du
magasin e-commerce
s'apaisent a pesé quand vous êtes arrivé
2 % des ventes donc ça c'était avant
aujourd'hui ces quatre ça doublé mais ça
reste seulement quatre pour son objectif
crois que c'est 10% en 2026 comment vous
assurer que cet objectif sera atteint
comment m'assurer passé comme je vous
disais c'est x cours de course voyez là
le click and collect le dcp d'atteindre
10% horizon parce qu'on se dit pour son
final bon c'est 10 % c'est pas rien mais
c'est pas non plus pas la moitié de ce
chiffre d'affaires qui est un digital
non c'est pas la moitié contrairement à
la chine la moitié de son chiffre
d'affaires des gens digital pour vous
donner distribution alimentaire
absolument en chine mais on est déjà 50%
donc pour vous donner un ordre d'idée
sur la france en revanche les produits
surgelés représente sur le déjà 10% il
était à 7% avant la crise sanitaire ils
ont une part de marché de 10%
aujourd'hui donc finalement atteindre
les 10% ce serait rejoindre une norme du
marché à l'heure actuelle cette crise a
justement remis en avant les bénéfices
des surgelés alors certes on se dit
c'est stockables c'est pratique mais pas
sur mes pas que à l'heure où justement
l'environnement est une préoccupation
essentielle pour les français
on vient de découvrir que les surgelés
c'était aussi une manière de ne pas
gaspiller finalement son alimentation
france ont juste besoin voyez on remet
le paquet au congélateur et on peut
conserver deux ans avec effectivement
des qualités gustatives et
nutritionnelles qui restent intacts
pendant ces deux années donc à l'heure
où effectivement les français se
préoccupe de lentilles gaspillage on
entend aussi nous on veut des légumes
cueillis en saison c'est le cas des
surgelés ou vous à en consommer en toute
saison pour autant toutes nos campagnes
de légumes de fruits sont fait
effectivement saison plus d'un million
de nouveaux clients c'est ce que la
crise sanitaire vous a permis de
conquérir comment est ce qu'on fait pour
les conserver est ce que le digital
c'est aussi un levier pour les conserver
oui alors il ya plusieurs matières
manière de les conserver il faut aussi
les anime et il faut les connaître déjà
donc la date ait une vraie réponse par
rapport à ça donc donc notamment via la
carte de fidélité donc on les connaît on
voit ce qu'ils consomment et il est
intéressant de leur poussée des produits
qui les intéressent donc avec nos
produits et on les reconnaît et c'est
typiquement ce que fait un programme de
fidélité donc on les anime
systématiquement par rapport à leur
fréquence de visite à leurs produits de
prédilection alors anniversaire aussi
nos clients adorent qu'on leur offre un
gâteau au chocolat à l'occasion de leur
anniversaire
vous voyez c'est effectivement tout un
processus de connaissance et de
reconnaissance et péladeau qui est pour
convaincre les clients potentiels qui
est qu'ils ne viennent pas encore chez
vous encore une fois le digital c'est
aussi une solution le digital est une
solution c'est pour ça qu'on est en
train de réfléchir à multiplier
différents parcours de course donc on
regarde ce qui se fait et notamment on
peut on ne peut parler peut-être du
snack-bar connectés qui effectivement
voilà qui est une innovation aussi
digital chez picard qui est ni plus ni
moins un distributeur automatique dans
lequel effectivement vous pouvez avoir
recours à des produits surgelés 17 ans
tourne et que l'on trouve dans des
grandes entreprises des parcs
d'attraction des hôpitaux et on a ouvert
récemment des universités aussi avec ce
snack bar connectés si ce match
l'objectif c'est d'avoir un maillage
aussi le maillage du territoire
important là où ça fait sens donc
un ami 50 en france oui et donc voyez
l'objectif étant finalement multiplier
les points de contact avec nos clients
sur tous les instants de consommation il
ya un avant et un après dans
l'accélération de la transformation
digitale de chez picard avec votre
arrivée oui à leur marque de fabrique
n'est pas la seule mais c'est cette une
décision forte priorité urgente quand
vous êtes arrivé oui absolument donc je
pense que il ya un avant et un après
pour les clients parce qu'ils ont
désormais accès différents parcours de
course mais je pense aussi pour nos
équipes parce que aujourd'hui elles ont
la fierté finalement de tester
de nouvelles initiatives d'avoir des
résultats qui sont quand même
extrêmement intéressant on a fait une
année à +15 en progression de chiffre
d'affaires l'année passée donc donc on
assure aussi le marché tous les ans ah
oui je promets pas puisque 15 tous les
ans mais bon tout est permis on s'est
mis deux médiatrices de voile à 2
milliards de chiffre d'affaires en 2026
donc on a un plan de croissance
extrêmement ambitieux qui fait briller
les yeux de nos équipes avec la part
belle pour le digital merci en tout cas
cathy collart gère les bagages et de
picard on va maintenant s'intéresser et
parler d'un secteur qui s'est lui aussi
digitalisées en un temps record pendant
pendant confinement c'est la
restauration
et oui depuis la réouverture des
restaurants le qr code est devenu
incontournable pour consulter les menus
bonjour emilie un journal libyen alors
ce fameux code barre il est complètement
rentré dans les moeurs ça c'est une
évidence il a une autre fonction qui est
utile pour le secteur de la restauration
c'est de pouvoir payer l'addition la
douloureuse c'est ce que nous propose la
pite sound et qui a été lancée pendant
le confinement par les fondateurs de
l'enseigné du restaurant italien big
mama à ce moment là les restaurants ils
sont fermées en france mais il commence
à réouvrir aux états unis et en asie
avec les fameux qr codes sur les tables
des qr codes donc que les fondateurs ont
l'idée de détourner pour payer la note
alors au départ il équipe les
restaurants du groupe mais très vite le
bouche à oreille fonctionne et en
quelques mois ce sont 1600
établissements qui sont équipés en
france mais également au royaume uni et
en espagne ml comme on explique cette
déferlante pour le coup parce que
franchement aujourd'hui on paie déjà
sans contact avec eux avec sa carte
bancaire avec avec son téléphone qu'est
ce qu'il a de plus votre qr codes au
restaurant on va dire qu'il satisfait
autant le restaurateur que le serveur et
le client lors si on se place d'abord du
point de vue du client et bien le qr
nous fait gagner du temps quinze minutes
en moyenne par jour ce qui n'est pas un
luxe vous avez ce quinze minutes c'est
le temps qu'on passe à et les le serveur
a levé la main pour qu'ils nous voient
qu'ils nous dépose la note puis
l'appareil de carte bleue avec le qr
code tout ça c'est l'histoire ancienne
on paye en 10 secondes chrono alors
justement comment ça se passe le
paiement alors le qr est directement
relié au logiciel de caisse concrètement
c'est comme quand vous consulter le menu
vous flashez le code avec votre appareil
photo vous ouvrez le lien et vous
cliquez sur l'option à régler mon
addition si vous avez déjà enregistré
votre carte bleue sur votre téléphone ça
prend quelques secondes ça prendra un
petit peu plus de temps si vous devez
rentrer vos coordonnées bancaires
ensuite vous payer via visa mastercard
google paie ou apple paix ou soit il
c'est vous qui voyez si vous êtes
plusieurs convives vous pouvez même
partager l'addition en quelques clics et
puis cerise sur le gâteau david vous
pouvez également payé le pourboire
directement sur l'appli compte plus
besoin d'avoir de la petite monnaie sur
ce quoi et puis maintenant que les
pourboires sont défiscalisées ça vaut le
coup c'est vrai alors ça pousse surtout
le client a donné plus l'appui a fait le
calcul on comptabilise 40 % 2 pour boire
en plus dans tous les établissements
équipés finalement c'est assez logique
parce que les clients sont dans de
meilleures dispositions ils vont donc
être sans doute plus généreux avec leur
server le serveur qui lui a plus de
temps pour s'occuper de ses convives
pour leur expliquer tel plat une telle
recette vous voyez avec le qr code même
s'il est dématérialisé il ré humaniser
en quelque sorte les relations entre le
client et le serveur donc ce gagnant on
voit bien pour pour le serveur plus de
pourboire et moins de stress aussi sont
clairement un des meilleurs conditions
de travail d'ailleurs il semblerait
qu'en ce moment des serveurs soient
tentés de quitter leur job pour
rejoindre des établissements qui sont
équipés ce fameux qr codes ce qui dans
ce contexte de pénurie de main d'oeuvre
est loin d'être négligeable je rappelle
que le secteur a perdu en un an deux
cent trente sept mille salariés selon
les données de la dares et que cent
mille postes ne sont toujours pas
pourvus on a parlé milliers d avantage
pour pour le client pour le serveur quid
du restaurateur le restaurateur a
beaucoup à gagner aussi déjà en termes
de fluidité la société a noté une hausse
de 12% dans la rotation 1 par rapport
aux établissements qui ne sont pas
équipés et puis d'un point de vue
financier évidemment le restaurateur n'a
plus de coûts fixes sur les transactions
plus de coûts de maintenance finalement
il ne paie qu'une commission variable
sur les paiements c'est ce qui lui coûte
grosso modo moitié moins cher qu'avec un
terminal de paiement classique dont vous
voyez c'est vraiment du gagnant gagnant
pour tout le monde ce qui explique
l'ascension fulgurante du qr code qui
est vraiment en train de révolutionner
le secteur de la restauration et sans
doute du commerce en général la piscine
des ailes s'est fixé pour objectif de
d'équipé 15000 restaurants d'ici 2022 et
elle vient de lever 100 millions de
tonnes voilà on le souhaite bonne chance
mercier millénaire voilà c'est la fin de
cette émission pourvu que ça dure des
missions qui rend les co-responsables
sur public sénat j'espère que ça vous
appelez mission revoir sur public sénat
ou en replay sur publicsenat.fr rendez
vous dans deux semaines
[Musique]